hey guys and welcome to episode 5 and a
half this is going to require some
explaining basically I said it in the
description of the last video as well as
in the comment section there but I made
a mistake again which I also made after
episode 3 that is I actually over wrote
this park file with another park I open
an empty sandbox used to try some
building ideas and I saved it under the
name grizzly Valley and by the time I
noticed that the auto-saves also saved
over the grizzly Valley safe and this
basically meant that I lost grizzly
Valley I still have a backup but that
backup was from before I started
building this main street so basically
this entire Main Street is lost and that
is why I also wanted to call this
episode 5 point 5 in the end I sort of
feel like this isn't really leading up
to anything though I still wanted to
make this episode out of this to just at
least do something with the footage and
be able to show off what the Main Street
looked like in the end but it's also a
bit of a short episode since it was cut
short before I could actually finish it
so that's why I decided to call this
five point five and now something which
I should say though is that it's not too
bad and I definitely won't end this
series at all I the main idea of this
series was in the end to try and
experiment with new things and see
whatever you can really build in the
game and for that purpose I think it's
actually been a lot of fun and also
really good practice to build this main
street's and I'm just really glad that I
still have the footage as well so I will
still continue the park and there isn't
too much to worry about that I won't
rebuild the main street in this way
since I just figured purely because I
want to try this since the game is still
an alpha just to experiment with things
I would like to build a new sort of Park
entrance area at some point in the
future but before that I also want to
finish the rest of the park so I'll just
tell you whatever I do from this point
onward I just really wanted to show this
video still because it would sort of be
a shame not to use it at all and
definitely since this is the last memory
of this Main Street which I have no
other thing of than just the videos and
photos that I have
right now so yeah about a couple of the
buildings they're always building here I
wanted to make some buildings which are
very similar to what I already had but
still with all the buildings try out
some new things so over here I wanted to
quickly see how well it would actually
work to have a dormer without any
inclined roof on top of it since that
earns one tile roofs that actually go
down on both sides which is something
which I would have really liked to use
there but the very fact that they're not
in the game so it makes it hard to make
dormers and exactly the way you would
want to see them sometimes and that's
why it's just wanted to quickly try out
what a flat dormer would actually look
like and some other smaller details like
this over here as well where I wanted to
try these chimneys over these pillars
and see how they would actually work
which I have to say Kim knees are
probably among the most versatile pieces
in this game and you can use them
practically for anything and also very
important of course is that I wanted to
add many different flags not quite as
many as the Main Street USA but still
really wanted to have some flags which
in general you really find that if you
have a building and you're just kind of
kind of yeah it could be better about it
you just sort of hang lots of flags on
it and then it's bound to look a little
bit better at some point in time at
least it helps definitely and then over
here in this corner I wanted to have
another building which is quite similar
to the building which I have in the same
place on the other side of the Main
streets just with a slightly different
style of course and again try some
different combinations of details and
see what you can really do in the game I
think I actually ended up trying another
type of dormer for this building and
also have a round roof but like what was
actually the most fun thing to try with
this building is to use these little no
entirely sure that kind of like cornice
pieces but not exactly sure what they're
actually called
I use them all the time though but I
never really pay attention to the names
basically this piece of you sink it into
the wall I figured and layer them like
that you could create the look of a sort
of beige-ish planks which you very often
see on Main streets or at least these
planks would be colored on Main streets
with all types of different colors
depending on what
but I really figured it would be nice to
try and definitely a good way to get
some different textures onto different
buildings in the main street yeah so I
didn't want to have that sort of round
ish mentality building I don't actually
it's probably it's French so it's
probably like Monza
or something like that but I'm terrible
at French so I'm sorry about that and
really the rest of the building is quite
simple as well what in the end turn out
to be my favorite parts of this Main
Street and also actually if there's May
of this video as well is a building
which is going to be next to this but
which I will only get to in a second
which is going to take the remaining
five minutes of the time-lapse which
would be an hour in-game this is
something which I haven't addressed yet
in this very series so I still got some
questions from people asking how long
this really takes but I usually almost
always speed up my video is 12 times so
that means that five minutes in game is
approximately one hour or in the
time-lapse that makes no sense
one hour in the game is approximately
five minutes of time-lapse so this
particular episode took a little over
two hours and most episodes takes
somewhere from three to five hours
really also sort of depends on how many
off-road shots and how much real time
parts I wanted to add in there so this
is where I think really one of my
favorite buildings in the main street
it's going to be and it's quite similar
to the buildings which I already have
I just wanted to mess a little bit more
with the entire Victorian facade idea
and make this one of the more fancy
buildings sort of just go nuts basically
with all of the details that I wanted to
try and get on there the only sort of
tough parts of it was the roof spire on
top of it where I was really hoping or
at least really thinking what would be
perfect for it is one of those very
typical main street spires which are
square shaped spires which slightly
points toward the top but still have a
little fence railing on top of them and
the flag of course but those are not in
the game so really figure this was the
next best thing really but apart from
nuts I'm actually really happy with how
this building turned out especially when
it comes to all the little details
like again wanted to use these chimneys
just to have some details on the pillows
and these cornerstones are absolutely
amazing and I'm completely addicted to
them so can stop using those either and
then it was actually quite interesting
to see how well the balcony actually
works as a cornice piece as well which I
was really happy with in the end I'm not
really sure what type of building it
would really be in an actual theme park
though I sort of just wanted to give
myself a wild card to well go wild with
the details I suppose and that's really
why I wanted to try this in the end it's
it also takes quite a lot of the other
buildings in a way it's also sort of the
accumulation of the entire Main Street
into one building and sort of just
putting everything that I learned in all
of the little tricks and and things that
I found along the way into one building
and see how that would all turn out so
in that sort of respect I really figured
it would be a nice conclusion to the
main streets but in a way it also turned
out to be a bit of a farewell of the
Main Street but yeah aside from that I
also wanted to work a little bit more
with some more contrasting colors on
this building I didn't have many blue
buildings specifically for the reason
because right now everything nearly
everything in the game is blue and I
wanted to avoid having too much blue but
I really figured in this case it would
be quite nice to have it just to make it
look a little bit more royal and even
have those little purple highlights
which I really wasn't sure about that's
actually a sign behind there - for me
the purple highlights on the top of the
walls but I'm actually quite happy with
how that one worked out as well so I may
want to combine those two pieces a
little bit more in the future like at
the moment they're like there are barely
any options to actually make colourful
buildings but I definitely think that
the best way to do so at some point in
time is definitely by using these signs
to get some different colors into your
buildings and over here as well I very
similar to the buildings which I have on
the corners of the plaza with the
fountain in the middle of it
I wanted to sink these arches a little
bit into the wall but not entirely so
they still stick out a little bit but
they don't seem like separate walls
either and the same sort of goes for the
pillars there
or Gio's place inside of the balcony
there and not actually on the very
corner of the grid so this is one of
those buildings which really has
different grids for the different pieces
which I think and this is also something
which I've discussed and forums and in
many chats as well I don't think I've
really said it in a video to explicitly
I really think the best potential and by
far the most flexible part of this
building system is the very fact that
you can have different grids for
different parts of buildings but also
different elements within one building
so say put all of the pillars on one
grid and all of the walls on another
grid because it's this very system which
may actually seem very limiting if you
just start the game actually find that
many people try to get used to building
things with just one grid per building
but I actually think the most flexible
and really the most freeform parts of
the entire building system is how you
can use different grids for different
parts just because you can put
everything in two directions and ways
that is so completely free but you still
have can some control over it because
you can still keep different parts that
you want in different grids or even move
those different parts or at once that
it's so useful and it's so flexible at
the same time which is really something
where I think this game is really
amazing I think one of the most
important parts probably as a game in
this genre to actually be able to cross
is to be able to attract both the
players who are quite casual and just
want to build some simple stuff and have
fun in the game much like just playing
rollercoaster tycoon but on the other
hand you also want to try to convince
players like me who are complete nerds
and shut themselves up in their room to
try to make realistic theme parks in
games to actually buy your game as well
and that's sort of like the two markets
which you somehow have to both
capitalize on which I think a feature
like this building system is actually
really good for it can be really simple
and easy to use if you want it to be but
it can also be so incredibly flexible
and I just wanted to quickly by the way
have some backstage areas over here as
well just to make it seem a little bit
more like a real-life theme park and
also to see if you can actually build
the backstage areas and I do have to say
I was actually really surprised that
frontier added those little air
conditioners and things like that you're
able to actually make the backstage
areas which is something which is
actually really cool to see because
obviously theme parks are completely
fake but you don't want your guests to
see that you sort of just put up the
facades literally and figuratively to
try to convince them that they're in
this sort of fantasy world of the theme
park but behind all that you still have
the machinery and it's really cool to
see that frontier actually edit that as
well anyway I still have two pictures
which are the only pictures that I still
have of the finished Main Street as a
sort of goodbye this is one picture of
the little city hall building I'm not
sure if I can you want to call it a city
hall or a courthouse but either one of
those things it's basically something
like that and then there's also this
picture of the other corner
I didn't save any pictures of anything
else yet I was really figuring I would
do that later on but alas I lost the
main street but that said I will still
continue to keep building on this park
and will definitely want to explore some
different themes and different styles in
the future videos and definitely won't
add one and the series here and if I
ever get back to the entrance of the
park I won't rebuild the main streets in
the shape that it was simply because I
think it's a it's a bit of a waste of
time really and there was only like 13
hours I would much rather put into it
try to see what else is possible in the
game and I have no idea yet what I'm
gonna do with it but something else
that's basically what I want to say I
guess anyway thanks for watching this
sort of one-off video and next time I'll
try to come back to your regularly
scheduled not deleted Park files so
thanks for watching and see you later